hey youtubers is Charlie this is going
to be my Warcraft review so just careful
for spoilers if you guys haven't seen it
yet I'll do my non-spoilery part first
and then I'll do Easter eggs so here we
go I thought the movie did a really good
job of capturing the grandeur of the
game the game itself is so big I would
be very surprised if you've never played
any version of it this is largely based
on the first game orcs and humans so
there's a lot of familiar territory that
you see in World of Warcraft like Elwynn
forest you see a lot of the big cities
you see dalaran and then there's a lot
of like funny little bits that they
added in as you can imagine even though
Blizzard makes a bunch of different
games they'll probably a Starcraft movie
at some point they would love to see
sequels to this so this first movie just
kind of sets the universe up you'll
recognize a lot of the characters even
if you're not super familiar with the
lore of Warcraft so they did tune it
just a little bit so that you could take
someone who doesn't know what Warcraft
is and they'd be able to follow the film
but people who play the game or
definitely going to enjoy it way more so
as you'd expect with the movie this
ambitious there are some story issues
the human parts aren't nearly as good as
the orc parts but it is like next level
CG seriously I've never seen magic look
this awesome on screen the way it looked
on screen like just like the actual
effects of it and then the way they used
it can't wait to see what happens when
they make the next movie when you go see
it you'll understand why it took him so
long to make this they've been
developing a Warcraft movie for over 10
years Sam Raimi was originally attached
but then it just it took so long and it
kind of fizzled out the technology
wasn't quite there but the orc stuff in
this movie is just so awesome you
connect with their character so easily
it's amazing how there's that much in
balance between the CG actors in the
human actors of the actual human actors
and it does feel like some of the roles
were miscast but I think that was
largely due to the way they fill us a
lot of the sets weren't CG like they
built
Elwynn forest to film on it instead of
trying to duplicate it with some
real-life forest so they made some weird
choices and as you can imagine like
Captain America Civil War the airport
scene where everyone's fighting that is
100% CG all the actors every last frame
in that is completely CG that part of
the movie totally made in a computer so
it was amazing right so all the scene
in Warcraft that were completely CG like
all the orc stuff were 100% totally
awesome the only time the movie falters
a little bit is when they try to
integrate the real-life like the human
actors performances into scenes like
that normally it's the opposite normally
all the human stuff you'd expect would
be the best in the CG would look bad but
most of the CG in this movie is better
than any CG that I've seen in the last
year Captain America Civil War blended
it a little more seamlessly with the
human bits but again largely I think
that's due to Marvel just having more
experience filming stuff like that this
is the very first Warcraft Blizzard
collaboration with legendary so I think
they'll get a lot better with the sequel
and if you guys are wondering if they're
going to make another movie they're
definitely going to make another movie
it may like 90 million dollars just in
China opening weekend so even if it
doesn't make a billion dollars in the
United States it's still going to make a
billion dollars internationally so we
will definitely work our way to Arthas
Lich King if you guys don't know what
that is please go play Warcraft 3 then
play World of Warcraft you will be
totally blown away but I'll just go see
it you'll understand what I'm talking
about when I say the human bits just not
quite as good as the ORAC parts so it's
a great movie it'll definitely feel like
the first time you logged in to world of
warcraft and but just like oh my god
look at this amazing world so getting
into spoiler territory I'm going to talk
a little bit about Easter eggs first big
one murlocs
it was so awesome it was just a very
brief moment is there riding through
Elwynn forest you just hear this merlok
gurgling as they ride by we get to go
inside cares and we meet Medivh who
opened the dark portal in the game he
opens it in the movie - so even though
they changed a little bit about his
backstory they are true to the narrative
they even model some of the big fights
at the end of the film after boss fights
like when they're fighting the big golem
it looks like a boss fight Medivh has
different boss forms so even though the
stories from the classic RTS game they
borrow some of the mechanics from World
of Warcraft we see a summoning stone the
orcs chanting a lot we see cold Dan
communing with Mannoroth who's part of
the Burning Legion which will probably
make it into the sequel there were a
couple in-game cinematics that they
tried to copy with shots in the film
like medivh turning into a raven from
Warcraft 3 there was even something from
the beta for World of Warcraft Legion
the beta that's going on right now
now that they added to the film really
late during that final fight between
Lothar and black hand so they're
actually I mean they did kind of pull
some stuff from the MMO even though
technically the story of the film was
from the old-school games through the
course of the film or Grimm takes
command of the Frostwolf he has his
Doomhammer weapon it doesn't have the
Frostwolf insignia on it yet but
presumably after the events of the film
have put it on there the end credits
music like the soundtrack that plays
while the credits are rolling is
actually the soundtrack that plays at
the world of warcraft login screen just
like that classic theme song and they
don't really explore it but they deal a
little bit with the other Alliance races
this is largely humans versus orcs in
this film we go to Ironforge for a like
a quick bit we see some of the dwarves
presumably like all the other races of
the Alliance we'll see more in the next
film and we actually see Draenei even
though the Draenei aren't really big in
this film we do see a bunch of them in
cages when they're opening the portal
for the first time to get to Azeroth I
didn't catch it the first time I watched
it but supposedly eben Chill which is
going to be one of the new legendaries
staffs for the Legion expansion was
featured in the movie so I'll be
interested to see if in the next movie
they continue to do that were they
teased stuff that's coming in future
Warcraft expansions like the movies in
the game try to work with each other
like they model some stuff in the game
after stuff they do in the movies and
they use the movies to highlight some of
the stuff that's coming in the game like
some of the really special items but as
of right now the only thing I know
they're going to be following up on in
any future movie will be the Burning
Legion they have to address them because
they really only tease you with the idea
of fel which is basically blood magic
that corrupts the orcs and turns them
green which is where we get to thrall
who is like the end tag for the orc
parts of the movie that there's a couple
end tags where everyone's like you know
for the [ __ ] like the Alliance is
banded together and we see a little baby
thrall go crazy probably the funniest
Easter Egg though is when Khadgar sheeps
one of the guards it just poof it just
right out of the game it's just so
hilarious I got a huge laughs in my
theater so you'll probably spot at least
a couple Easter eggs when you see it
just expect future films to treat Easter
eggs that way to just you know funny
little things from the game little
aspects of gameplay but let me know in
the comments what did you think about
the film and what do you want them to do
for the next story keeping in mind that
they have to push further into Burning
Legion so I definitely think we will see
the lich king in the next movie even if
the film doesn't revolve around him
it'll introduce his character at least
but what's going to happen is there's a
whole bunch of stuff going on this
weekend Voltron just dropped on Netflix
I'm going to be doing a video for the
first couple of episodes tomorrow
it's made by the same people that made
Legend of Korra so it just looks goddamn
beautiful and new Game of Thrones coming
on Sunday so see you guys this weekend a
lot of awesome stuff happening while you
guys wait for my next video you can
click here for my Lady Stoneheart Game
of Thrones theory and you can click here
for all about the new character coming
to the flash season 3 thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight